so without much more ado I would like to
ask president going to come up to the
podium thank you
thank you very much well let me be
probably the last one or the eighth one
or something like that to say welcome to
Carnegie Mellon and for those of you not
from Pittsburgh welcome to our great
city we're very excited for this week
this has been a wonderful few days for
Pittsburgh and I hope the next two days
will be even better the attention that
we're getting feels very good right now
and i think it's it's well deserved i
want to thank the atlantic council for
partnering with us in this way i'm very
proud of the volume that was produced in
this symposium that unfortunally come to
now i wish i could have been there last
night longer than i was and this morning
about I understand it's gone very well
many many people have made this possible
and I thank them all but I want to
single out Chiron Skinner who conceived
of this used her tremendous talents and
force of will to make sure it happened
and realized the product beautifully and
I thank Chiron for doing this and once
again making a great contribution to
this University I'm going to be his
brief as I can and still convey what i
want to because this is a distinguished
panel and i look forward to being part
of it before i get really to the topic
at hand which is education in the
context of global economic development I
want to spend a little bit on the issue
of Pittsburgh it's highly relevant to
the topic so I don't feel bad about that
but the question on everybody's lips are
most people's lips since President Obama
made his announcement a few weeks ago
that the g20 would be here was why
Pittsburgh famous famously in the
Pittsburgh Press reported over and over
again
was the titters and laughing in the
White House press room when Pittsburgh
was announced the kind of treatment by
the way pittsburghers are completely
used to and have no problem which is
part of the story of Pittsburgh but any
event it's a great question why
Pittsburgh and the answer is even better
and highly relevant to the topic of this
panel the short version is at the core
to the answer is the sector now known as
the EDS and meds education and medicine
the universities and the health system
here in pittsburgh and in particular
carnegie mellon university university of
pittsburgh in the university of
pittsburgh medical center these three
institutions together have become the
major force for employment in this
region and the major source of new jobs
both in terms of company creation and
attracting companies and creating jobs
and it's a great story one of the
factoids about Pittsburgh that surprises
many people is that we're actually fifth
in America in terms the number of PhDs
per thousand people in the population
who would have thought Pittsburgh of all
places and it's because of these
universities both the people we attract
in the people we educate Carnegie Mellon
in particular embraced Pittsburgh's
economic development is our strategic
priority when we developed a strategic
plan when I first came in 97 we had five
priorities one of those was
internationalization which I'll come
back to in a moment and the other was
Pittsburgh and its economic and cultural
and artistic development and we've done
a lot our our own research sponsored
research basis more than doubled in that
time and that creates very attractive
jobs for the city we changed the way we
did technology transfer to emphasize
company creation in Pittsburgh and to do
it easier more easily and more quickly
so the burden on faculty wouldn't be so
great we've spun
more than 230 companies out of this
University we've worked to attract
companies and in something which is
probably unique for a private university
we partner with the state of
Pennsylvania built a building on our
campus of the edge of campus which now
has in it Intel Apple Google and a
Microsoft Research Lab the only building
in the world that can boast such a
collection and they don't fight either
as so far as I know and recently Disney
opened up their first ever research
center right across the street from the
building i just mentioned only because
that building is full and now we're
trying to build another one and we've
done much of this in collaboration close
collaboration with the university of
pittsburgh and UPMC we work together
very closely and in many other ways we
are a major part of the answer by
pittsburgh and a major demonstration of
how crucial education and educational
institutions are for economic
development we are the answers to why
Pittsburgh and was able to make the
transformation that it did now the other
priority I mentioned was the
internationalization go which goes right
to the topic of today's panel and I just
want to touch on a couple of things in
the context of what kind of game Ellen
is doing or has done but that connects
directly to the themes and the papers
that you'll find in the in the book and
I'm sure we'll be talking about in a
moment so we adopted
internationalization as a treated
strategic priority and in doing so we
basically had two things in mind one was
the preparation of our students wherever
they are but especially in Pittsburgh to
be successful in a globally connected
world and the other was being more
international as a university including
going to other places in opening
campuses and programs with regard to the
story here on this campus it's a very
mixed bag and one that
I hope we'll explore here on the panel
certainly with Susan Polanski on and I'm
sure we will in part and probably with
Pradeep as well and maybe some of our
visitors on the one hand we've seen a
very significant rise in the number of
international courses and offerings we
have here in Pittsburgh on our campus
here and we've seen a very strong
response to this by our student body and
a demand for it and I'm thinking about
in particular all the programs that
Chiron has been involved in our
international relations program now I
forgot what we call it now global
politics thank you which is different
from global societies and someday maybe
someone will explain that to me but in
any event students are really responding
to them and whereas i read in Susan's
paper now the percentage is eight
percent nationally eight percent eight
point six percent of American
undergraduates take a foreign language
during college amazingly low here at
Carnegie Mellon it's about half eight
point six percent versus fifty percent
here at Carnegie Mellon fantastic stuff
and what and we're very proud of our
modern languages department which is
much more than just learning a language
students really get immersed in in
cultural issues and diversity of their
classes is spectacular that's all great
on the other hand we did a survey of our
undergraduate students and it was
amazing to me actually shocking how many
of them really don't care about the rest
of the world and know very little about
and don't want to be troubled about it I
want to be an engineer don't bother me
with all this stuff it's kind of like
this incredible disconnect I'd say more
than half of our undergraduates and I
don't know what the number is but it's a
lot too many have not embraced internet
internationalization at all on the same
campus we've got all of this stuff going
on in terms of international relations
global politics in modern languages
I hope the panel will explain this to me
as I said the other part of this was
going to the world now and a decade
after we started doing that we have 16
degree programs in 12 different
countries around the world and as you
heard a campus in Qatar where we do
undergraduate education the only place
outside of Pittsburgh where we do all
the rest are masters and PhD programs I
was particularly taken by some of the
issues raised in the paper by Russell
Berman where he talked about the
asymmetry of international education
what he meant by that was international
students non-us students come to
American institutions either here or
that were there if there's a branch like
us where they live and they focus on
technical details engineering or science
business maybe and they don't really get
exposed to the humanities and Social
Sciences the way undergraduates in this
country do we're at the same time
American students enroll or students who
enrolled in American universities if
they have an international experience it
tends to be not the kind of educational
experience we would necessarily hope and
they get kind of a narrow view of what
international experiences are that's the
asymmetries talking about he also talked
about the tension unavoidable tension
between the modernization of nations
with their traditional values and in
education is central and all of that and
he talked about the very poor state of
educational systems in many most maybe
all developing countries I'm not going
to respond to all of those but let me
tell you about one anecdote related to
our program in Qatar which gets really
in a way to all of these early on in our
time there which would have been about
six years ago the sheikha moza who is
the mirrors second wife and the one who
is
the visionary and leader of the
educational programs Qatar asked me to
come and see her I had an audience and
she did specifically to say to me the
following we're very impressed at how
culturally sensitive Carnegie Mellon is
you've been wonderful about being
respectful of our values here and not in
making a point of not imposing your
values on us she then went on to say but
the reason we invited you here is we
want your values she said something to
me which was stunning she said and I'm
just quoting her so don't jump on me and
my nation and she went on to say in Arab
nations corruption is too much a part of
the way we do things it's endemic in our
system you stand for honesty integrity
your reputation is all about that we
need to implant that into the future
leaders of our country the other thing
she said was you stand for excellence
and we and my country are too often
willing to settle for second best what
is mediocre these are the two things we
want from you so yes we appreciate your
cultural sensitivity continue to be so
but don't forget why you're here it's
not just about teaching the technical
details of computer science which is one
of the things we teach it's about
imparting those values as well one other
example we started programs masters and
PhD programs in Portugal about three
years ago and Pradeep Khosla has been
leading that effort I was just there
last week for a board meeting for the
body that oversees this what was
stunning to me was how much the culture
of the universities in Portugal has
started to change because of our
involvement with them which we would say
is a victory in
success and the Portuguese leadership
would as well but this notion of
cultural change in the transformation of
educational institutions in the role of
us research universities in that is a
very important one on one that we're
experiencing finally Thomas Spillers
paper talks about new technology for
education I just want everybody to know
when you're president of the University
which is hosting the conference you've
got the prerogative to do this kind of
thing this is a flat commercial the only
reason I bring it up I want you to know
about our open learning program here
where we are have created more than a
dozen fully contained college-level
courses available on the internet we're
doing this an experimental way haven't
spent a lot of money given to us by the
Hewlett Foundation this is of a quality
with potential for impact because it's
got built an assessment and feedback and
interaction with the student at a level
that simply has not been seen before and
with the support of the Gates Foundation
the Lumina Foundation and more Hewlett
we expect to be rolling this out in a
very big way to American community
colleges but we see this is all on the
way to providing really high-quality
self-contained technology delivered
college level education to the world
that's our goal and it's happening here